- So, you recently opened up
about having panic attacks.
I didn't know that about you.
- Yeah, I moved out at 15,
so I started having panic
attacks about that age.
Didn't know what they were.
And then when I was homeless,
they hit a whole new level.
And so I started inventing
tools and techniques
to help me with them.
Haven't had them in ages.
And then suddenly when I was filming,
maybe it was "The Masked Singer,"
I had my first panic attack in ages.
- Well, probably 'cause
you were in a costume
that you couldn't breathe in, maybe?
- Claustrophobic, yeah, I
was a little claustrophobic.
- Yeah.
- So I started posting,
'cause we help kids with anxiety disorders
and those types of things
and so started posting more about it
(audience applauds)
just to help people
understand what they are
and the things you can do to help.
- I had no idea what they were
until the first time I was pregnant.
And I had one while driving.
- Oh god, that's the worst.
- And I was terrified.
It was like, I froze and
I'd never had one before,
but for some reason, I don't know,
chemically something
happened and I had one.
I was like, "This is no good."
Like you freak out.
- Your brain literally goes offline,
so all the blood drains
out of your frontal lobes
and goes right to your amygdala.
And your vascular system changes,
your blood pressure changes.
- What's up, Bill Nye?
- Finding things to go-
- Geez. I was like,
"Okay, that's amazing."
- Well, if you find things
that force the blood back
into your processing centers.
So, smell, taste, touch.
That forces your brain to
deal with the information,
so it forces it to go back online.
- Forces it to come back.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah.
- What in the world.
Have you guys ever suffered
from any kind of panic attack
or any kind of?
Maybe like on set or something?
Do you all ever get like that?
Like I would get terrified
of what y'all do,.
- But I think it's so validating
hearing the kind of scientific side of it,
to hear that it is a
chemical reaction happening
and something that needs to
be addressed in that way.
- Yeah, that reasoning part of your brain
literally goes offline.
There's no blood there.
It's fascinating.
- And that's the panic.
Have you ever had anything like that?
- Of course, yeah, absolutely.
Just something that just puts you
in your place completely
and you can't move.
- Yeah, and it's your
brain noticing patterns.
It only takes two data points
that your brain, even your
subconscious recognizes,
to some other time that might
have been traumatic for you.
And so its, I don't know-
It took me a long time to figure out
like what were those two things. You know,
so then I could start creating a plan.
- Your body keeps score, cause
you go back to that trauma
and you don't realize
but your brain does that.
It remembers it.
- Yeah, its the pattern.
It's fascinating.
- It's exhausting.